greetings Nephilim this is stephanie
johnson AKA ly lyra the community
manager for diablo 3 at blizzard
entertainment in this video we'll be
highlighting some of the major system
updates and new features included in
patch 201 we've got a ton of cool stuff
to cover so let's get started first up
is the highly anticipated revision 2
itemization something we like to call me
to point out with loop 2 point 0 we've
changed the way stats on items are
allocated and organized going forward
all new items that drop will have their
stats separated into two categories
primary and secondary primary stats
include main stats damage increasing
stats such as a tack speed or critical
hit chance defensive stats such as armor
for life per second and some new steps
like bonus splash damage or percent
increase to one of your class skills
these are stats that will directly
impact the DPS toughness and life values
displayed on your hero's character sheet
secondary stats are generally more
focused on utility unlike primary stats
they don't directly impact the power of
your hero but can still change your
gameplay in meaningful ways some
examples of secondary stats include
increased pickup radius bonus experience
and gold find items can roll up to four
primary stats and two secondary stats
and more importantly stats in one
category will never compete against the
other loot 2 point 0 also introduces the
smart loot system as of patch 201 and
moving forward into Reaper of souls
every time an item drops including
legendary and set items it now has a
chance to be what we call a smart drop a
smart drop is an item that takes your
current class into consideration when
rolling it stats as a result players
should now find more items that are
relevant and useful to the hero their
plane an addition certain stats no
longer have a chance to roll on class
specific items so say goodbye to mighty
belts with dexterity or strength mojo's
and hello to better loot
of course primary stats secondary stats
and smart drops are just the tip of the
itemization iceberg loot to point out
also includes the following changes new
item affixes have been added keep an eye
out for splash damage cooldown reduction
resource reduction bonus physical damage
and class specific skill bonuses item
stat ranges have been narrowed this
means that instead of an item having a
range of 1 to 200 strength for example
its range might now be more like 140 to
200 meaning that on average items should
be much more powerful these stat ranges
can now also be viewed in game to see
how well your item rolled simply press
and hold ctrl while its tooltip is open
all new legendary and set item drops
will now be binal an account looking for
the most powerful gear will suit up and
mow down some demons and finally all
legendary items have been reworked with
one or more of these points in mind and
many legendaries have also had their
powers revisited with the goal of making
them build changing please note that
these changes will only affect new items
that drop your existing items will
remain untouched and will not be
affected by any of the updates we've
discussed
up next is Paragon with patch 201 the
Paragon system has received free major
updates 1 the Paragon level cap has been
removed to these levels are now shared
across your account normal heroes and
hardcore heroes will have separate
shared Paragon levels and 3 the rewards
for gaining Paragon levels have
drastically changed let's take a look
each time you gain a Paragon level
you'll now be provided a point to spend
in one of four categories core offense
defense or utility core points can be
spent on your classes primary attribute
vitality movement speed or bonus class
resource offensive points focus on
increasing your damage output and
efficiency and include attack speed
cooldown reduction critical hit chance
and critical hit damage defensive points
include stats that help improve your
survivability options include bonus life
percentage bonus armor resistol and life
regeneration finally utility points
include more specialized stats that
allow players to refine their builds
these points can be spent on boones like
area damage resource cost reduction life
on hit and gold find the goal of the new
Paragon system is designed to give you
greater control over your hero promoting
variety and build options and offering
more character customization than ever
before
moving on to difficulty game difficulty
settings have changed quite a bit in the
latest patch how exactly well first
we've removed the tiered progression
system from Diablo 3 under this system
players were required to progress
linearly through normal nightmare hell
and inferno completing the campaign on
one difficulty before unlocking the next
this system has been replaced with what
we call dynamic difficulty monsters will
now level up alongside your hero growing
in power and abilities as you do in
addition we've added 10 new difficulty
settings replacing the old monster power
system these new difficulties are normal
hard expert master and torment one
through six normal heart and expert
difficulties will be immediately
available to all players while master
and torment difficulties well unlock as
players progress through the campaign
note that unlocking a difficulty on one
hero will unlock it for all heroes on
your account each increase in difficulty
level offers additional challenges and
greater golden experience rewards
players in torment will also be rewarded
with an increased chance to find
legendary items
with patch 201 were also introducing two
new social features clans and
communities plans are intended to be
smaller and invitation-only with a focus
on socialization clans also have the
ability to assign a clan tag that will
display next to a member's name in game
through the clan you I members can share
news chat with one another in a private
channel check out member profiles and
their legendary drops and plenty more
it's a great way to organize your play
and keep in touch with those you game
with the most in addition to clans
players can also join communities
communities are designed to be a place
where players can come together for any
number of reasons including play in the
same class frequenting the same fan
sites or living in the same geographical
area communities can be public or
private and support a nearly unlimited
number of members similar to clans
communities also offer a variety of
options for sharing information and
encouraging interaction between players
who have common interests but that's not
all check out some of these other cool
changes included in the patch chest
enshrines they'll have a chance to be
cursed starting an event when inspected
these events offer a variety of
challenges and will reward players with
gold experience and a radiant chest once
cleansed players will now occasionally
find pools of reflection while
adventuring which grant a 25-percent
buff to experience game this buff will
persist until you reach a set amount of
bonus experienced warrior hero dies
champions and elites can now spawn with
five challenging new monster ethics
a--'s including frozen pulse orbiter
poison enchanted thunderstorm and
wormhole and last but not least we were
visited and revamped all the original
hero classes be sure to review our
official 2010 tea for more information
about these features
that wraps up our recap of patch 201 we
look forward to hearing your thoughts on
the Diablo 3 forms and can't wait to
share more about our upcoming expansion
reaper of souls as March 25th draws near
thanks for joining us and we'll see you
in sanctuary